so you want to play god huh
great it's pretty easy with the far cry
4 level editor welcome to my humble home
over here is the party room excuse me
excuse me uh you'll notice i have uh all
the latest drinks
got some fat beats kicking right now
got a nice game system over here play
anything you want and uh opium party to
the right
make yourself at home
oh barkeep i will have one cocaine
thank
you
if you'll just follow me outside into
the backyard we can enjoy a few rounds
in the death pit
by far the easiest way to learn who's
king of the jungle is to throw them in a
pit and let them duke it out for round
one let's do tigers vs bears
cool how about a bunch of honey badgers
versus humans
ugh maybe humans versus rhinos
humans versus wolves
i mean if you don't feel like doing
death matches you know the sky's pretty
much the limit for whatever we want to
make
i made noah's ark in like five minutes
all you need is time patience and more
time because the tools are actually
pretty finicky especially if you're on
console you can spend a few hours trying
to make a great animal bowling alley
just to realize that it didn't actually
work the way you wanted to
but with a little bit of elbow grease
and some dumb luck voila a wooden loop
it might look small but this stupid
thing took hours to perfect let's keep
going with the theme here um it'd be
good to have a nice sick jump we'll need
a pit
i'm gonna do that i'll fill it with some
tigers and bears of course then we'll
need some explosions
we'll put some barrels we'll
pretty much put them everywhere
you gotta give it some nice home touches
you know
lights and some
statues fire pit and bam you got a sick
jump track you want to play look up evil
knievel and give it a whirl or play one
of the other ridiculous insane ass
levels the world is your oyster so blow
that [__] up
you